oh speaking of it looking very ugly
you're not going to believe this
donald trump was convinced that china
had a hurricane gun
that they were using to shoot hurricanes
at the united states
let that sink in trump thought china
had a hurricane gun
a rolling stone article
trump kept asking if china was shooting
us
with a hurricane gun
the then leader of the free world also
inquired whether the u.s could bomb
china in retaliation for the alleged
hurricane attack so he wanted to bomb
mexico
and he also wanted to bomb china
look at this
near the beginning of trump's time in
office the then president had a pressing
question for his national security aides
and administration officials
does china have the secret technology a
weapon even to create large man-made
hurricanes and launch them at the united
states and if so would this be an act of
war by a foreign power and if so could
the u.s retaliate militarily
trump repeatedly asked about it
according to two former senior
administration officials and a third
person briefed on the matter
a former trump official recently said
quote it was almost too stupid for words
i did not get the sense he was joking at
all
wow
the sources tell rolling stone that
trump started interrogating national
security officials and other staffers
about the alleged weapon during the
first year of his presidency and it
would pop up sporadically at least until
the end of 2018.
two of the sources recall that as trump
got deeper into the second year he
started to drop the topic but would
sometimes joke about it
the other former senior official said i
was present once when he asked if china
made hurricanes to send to us
he wanted to know if the technology
existed one guy in the room responded
not to the best of my knowledge sir i
kept it together until i got back to my
office i did not know where the then
president would have heard about it he
was asking about it around the time
maybe a little before he asked people
about nuking hurricanes now i have to
tell you
if you believe china has a hurricane gun
it's more logical that you would ask can
we nuke a hurricane like if once
you know how sometimes
things don't things don't make any sense
but they have like an internal logic so
like i'll give you an example this this
is a real example and you might say
david this is nothing like it but okay
if you believe abortion is murder
okay
it would follow from that that you might
say
prosecute women who have abortions for
murder okay i disagree with all of it i
disagree abortion i disagree with any of
it 100 against it against all of it but
i understand if you believed abortion
was murder you might believe all these
other things and try to do all these
other things okay
a little bit like that
if you believed china had a hurricane
gun where they could shoot hurricanes at
the country
it wouldn't be as crazy to be like could
we nuke a hurricane i don't know i
is that almost too charitable to trump
i'm not really sure
but this is uh you know
does the flu vaccine work for kovid was
one of the things trump asked early in
the pandemic what about injecting bleach
you might remember marjorie taylor
green's jewish space lasers
you might remember when congressman
louis gomer asked the national park
service if they could maybe alter the
orbit of the moon in order to ease
climate change okay this is up there
with that does china have a hurricane
gun and um the the theme here there's
really two themes one theme is
trump constantly
confused and ignorant about just about
everything that's that's one theme and
then the second theme
trump really wanting to know about
bombing all sorts of people remember
early in it was either late in the
campaign or early in the presidency
trump had to be told
why
we can't really have nuking europe on
the table like it just there's all these
geopolitical reasons why you can't we
can't nuke europe it's just not
something that you can do
uh he wanted to bomb mexico and mark
esper had to kind of talk and dissuade
him from doing that in order to go after
the cartels
he was asking about nuking hurricanes as
well as retaliating militarily against
china for what he suspected might be
some kind of hurricane gun in order to
shoot a hurricane the theme is bombing
bombing bombing and it is absolutely and
completely nuts uh we will have more on
this on the david pakman show instagram
page which you can find at david pakman
show we're going to take a quick break
we've got great stuff coming up on the
show today
one of our sponsors is crush organics
these guys are awesome they support the
show they have an excellent collection
of premium grade organic cbd products
crush organics has your oils your
topical creams gummies they even have
these great experience gift boxes which
are great for sending to someone this is
the one i received really beautifully
packaged crush has a daytime cbd blend
in peppermint as well as a nighttime
blend lots of people report cbd being
helpful for sleep crush's cbd topical
cream can be used on joints and muscles
definitely try the gummies too those are
great some people prefer the gummies
over the oils crush organics care a lot
about quality so you can feel good about
getting your cbd from them they're
always dropping new products pay
attention to the site and crush organics
are fans of the david pakman show just
like you i hope so they're giving you a
massive discount 40 off all products go
to crushorganics.us
and use the code pacman to save 40
the link is down below